what's happening there reject nation we
have ourselves a witcher episode two of
season two these are coming out in
random orders because we got no idea how
our lives are running anymore anywho uh
guys go ahead hit that like button that
would be amazeballs go ahead subscribe
click the notification bell so you're
properly notified when our reaction for
the next episode of witcher is uh full
length watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code for this show or over
at our patreon page become a super
reject today by joining there cover a
whole bunch of tv shows over there as
well lastly thank you to the boys over
at prepper for helping us edit down
these highlights let's get to it
[Music]
i was only at the market yet
we made more than a few pennies thanks
to your garden i can't wait to grow old
together you me and her the family we
always dreamed of
did we miss an episode i'm sure
yeah she got her uterus back super easy
barely an inconvenience
[Music]
this show does not like babies
every episode's going to start with her
saying that
[Music]
is that uh what's his name legolas
legolas uh of course astrid spoke of
these
built by elves to honor the prophets you
set fire to them in the early wars
better lost to history than humans
what is that guy's name it's on the tip
of my life
there you go
string them up
every passing day increases the risk of
us being found you don't need our people
anymore phil evangel
or has the white robe one visited your
dreams too gandalf she was visited by a
red robe one
once we find what we're looking for we
ship their heads back to aratusa as a
reminder of elven glory
these elves need to let it go
so long ago
he made a [ __ ] entrance he's back
wolf
you're home wolf
destiny
i had to make a few stops
hmm that's where i got from
all my teachings were imparted in grunts
you're all right
not like the hell [ __ ]
you should see the other guy
something's up with him yeah something's
off
i haven't crossed a leshi in a while i
can't you sounds lucky unless you're
aching for the sting of one of their
[ __ ] roots
have you been stung through that are you
gonna turn the only thing that puts one
down
six hours in that didn't occur to you
are you him oh
even serious laughing
you know peer pressure man
who the hell are you
princess sirler of cintra
nice to meet you
i am iron man buzz
the witchers
oh this isn't a castle
your highness
they're all shells
yep
what is up with this guy
suspicious of everything he does it's
gonna turn into a tree or something a
black robe
how did you know that
i've dreamt of one in red
and the elves talked about a white
yeah
you got to pay attention john are you
the philippandrol of the songs
the edge of the world the leader who
rose against the lioness the lying bard
in his tunes hey
hey hey we know a bard
we've dreamt of robe figures too
guiding us
hers is red mine is black
don't you think it's racist yours is
black
but i would still never go back
she's not my daughter
oh
well in that case i could take her in
she'd have the boys eating out of her
hand
esco found some friends down the
mountain
they shouldn't be here
and they should know better that's a
trap
don't look don't look too you're you're
just too inappropriate too adult for you
all i say is
when i find a princess the last thing
i'm going to do is
play night
grab them by that wound oh oh
that's going
got a better
huh
he's gonna kill her isn't he yeah
there's something worse
how to cook humans behold the mother of
forests the deathless mother nesting in
dreams
it's an incantation
about a hut with no doors
my father he used to scare us with
stories about the witch in the woods
does she and i get a vote on joining
your prayer circle
what do you think
let's go girls
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
gosh no one noticed the itch
no one noticed that
one of you noticed him kept scratching
there you've never heard of somebody
getting impaled by one of these things
if you're wrong
if the dreams don't mean what you think
beyond the mother of forests
the deathless mother
turn your front to me
hot
hot
basilisk legs
that was cool have you seen cyrilla i
saw him pounding white gold and dancing
on the table
[Laughter]
i was hoping she'd do as i say
kids never do what you say
we had a chat and then i sent her to bed
and she did what i said
you were the last surviving witcher
after kenmore and fell you won a batch
of mutated orphans
are you ready no
but you protected us anyway
no
i told you how to fend for yourselves
but in a way that was protecting us
yeah one hour to fend for yourselves
teach you
oh goodness here we go i'll find cirilla
do what you do best
stay and fight
maybe unless you wanted to be more
people here so could reproduce in some
way somehow perhaps yeah
how great would it be if they just
killed off all the witchers
it's only gear up left rest
it's just the path has been hard and the
path forward will be harder still
but i can help you
[Music]
oh boy
path to true strength lies not in humble
faith
but in believing in oneself and seizing
one's destiny
what is this the first pure elf for
years
oh damn why haven't you thought to
porter yourself free
she wants to understand what this is
move
[ __ ] part of tricks yes
denial
a tasty garnish
[Music]
some kind of baba yaga she's the witch
you will beg me to take it from you
and i
will
[Music]
i know exactly what's going on no one
needs to explain anything to me
oh god
oh
whoa
[Music]
wow
oh that is so cool yeah
wow
whoa cool james juan directed this
episode
that is neat yeah
i knew something
was wrong
i don't know what happened
oh no oh
i thought i could fight it
ag
i thought
you
could help
[Music]
oh hell yeah
yeah that design is gnarly yeah
hey you guys are a great team man
[Music]
oh hell no
he just got here
no come on daryl this is still your show
man oh
come on
he transformed so fast when it started
happening yeah that was not a gradual
process if she really is that evil
why does she let you go
stop her for evil plan yeah to mess with
our hoods
nowhere's safe now
a chance to survive
come on yen clear that web block
this continent was meant for no one all
you have to do siri is keep your sword
your training begins now
haskell just died and it goes right out
there to train her there's that illusion
broken
a fantastic looking episode
no expenses spared
my hair looks like i just came out of a
blizzard doesn't it
that's good volume
all right guys well here we are
witcher episode two today's theme
survival
that's what this whole what every
episode has like a really specific theme
and uh this one a lot with desperation
and survival this whole time i get it
for bird nah [ __ ] face [ __ ] a face it's
just some things just
it's used to get them by yeah that's
what yeah there's a huge
[ __ ] yeah that's what did she say
what did you say that was a cool line
yeah something about this that's how i
want to attack people's faith with that
line as you said the refuge of the
ignorant or something like that yeah or
or the desperate dude does the losers
yeah yeah all will you with faith
desperate suckers welcome to the atheist
rejects that's right
we don't believe in nothing nothing
matters nothing after nothing after this
there was nothing we don't believe
anything no science no religion
we were going to talk about some [ __ ]
today but we're all going to die so who
cares get love
um anyway you got a little carried away
it's a good riff a plus rip decent riff
decent rifle b plus riff i was really i
was really into that it was cool what is
the name of uh cake
shout out khan karen moorhen romero
yeah
witcher
frat house witcher fred has yeah
i wanna i hope we stay here a while
longer yeah it would be nice to actually
feel like it's a part of the story in
the world rather than just like a
one-episode side quest yeah well yeah i
mean we gotta develop the relationships
got other witchers you gotta get to know
the first witcher that we really got to
i mean you know obviously
if you know you've seen
uh nightmare of the wolf you you're
familiar with bessemer
especially in his elder years yeah in
that show you know that's what it really
covers you guys in that movie if you
guys haven't seen it yet it's all about
when he's old when he's old and wise
yeah
yeah
all about after the formative events of
his life that would affect the series
the whole time going man i wish we
watched when he was younger that would
have been so much better if i had seen
what the witchers were really up to
before they were all wiped out that
would have been sweet yeah get that good
additional context
that they summarize here in a couple of
sentences except oh there's something
about creating the monsters oh yeah it's
not really been touched heavily upon
just yet no you got to open a whole new
can of worms they got to make you make
sure you watch the damn movies that's
right
see they're not going to give you the
whole cheat sheet
expo dumps but you know enough for the
whole like uh you know uh father figure
themes and then you know the difference
between uh
uh protecting you know shielding
versus teaching how to survive teaching
how to protect one's self and that was a
cool little flip on the whole thing i
really like that conversation between
vesmer and geralt when geralt's like hey
hey i'm doing what i did because of you
and then vesamir was like nah man you
got my lessons all wrong i didn't really
want to take care of you guys
i want you guys to be able to know how
to take care of yourselves
it's even better than me taking care of
you jeez i can't you can't leech off me
forever
i already got this place to take care of
jeez go out find your own way it's the
most sarcastic witcher
we've ever done
but getting them together and they do
have great chemistry who's got playing
uh best mirror i feel like i've seen him
before but i can't play brian cox that's
right that's right definitely hancock's
from mexico
yeah
i'm pretty sure mine is way more
funnier and more accurate yes then
definitely brian branson your joke was a
riff on my name it was and not really on
the love so sorry i know there's an
alternate universe where slightly more
in shape brian cox could avoid the best
fear
based off the casting choice they
wouldn't that's
your joke was way way more insane it was
a little bit more apt compared to yours
yeah my joke sucked uh i gotta say it
sucked i'm just saying it was uh this
wasn't as finely as third on the bottom
yeah third from the bottom
we're gonna explore all of the potential
jokes before this is done god damn it
john stay on track we've got [ __ ]
elves to talk about phil evandrell
mm-hmm
he's back every time he shows back up it
never seems as exciting as you think
it's always like philadelphia heard
about you ah you're not really the star
that's yeah yeah yeah
every time he shows up
you're good when you're on screen but
you've got bigger people to answer too
plot-wise i know i'm going to have to
bite my words on that one though swallow
my tongue because i'm sure that they're
setting him up to be a
much bigger presence here yeah he
downplayed his accomplishments he's got
to be bigger he did that bard was
awesome yeah and
yeah so you have uh i mean it's weird to
have like this storyline where you have
yennefer and frangilla who it's like oh
it's cool they're actually starting to
get along now they're both captives and
they're it seems like they're starting
to get along with each other as they're
letting down this
path like you reference papa yaga
there's a little bit of um
gretel yeah a little bit more happens on
gretel so you have well it seems like
these past two episodes have really done
like spins on familiar fairy tales
because for this these two episodes
alone have really amped up the fantasy
fairytale vibe so much more
and it's like last episode really had
that applicable towards
you know geralt and siri and then in
this one it was really with our
sorceresses
sorceress seeds sore sources
sorcerer scissors right sorceresses is
so so scissors scissors
scissors by the sea surface
that's actually an incantation now that
was a good one hey we got one of the top
five brian cranston crap that was a good
one
yeah i'll stick to all iterations that
was funnier than the brian cox one most
people are like brian cox that was a
good one thanks thanks i'll be here for
uh the whole review yeah so uh
with the sources and really that was
young jennifer right
that's what i thought it was like a
younger version of herself
yes yeah i think so
she didn't have their her hunchback
oh [ __ ] you're right yeah it was that
maybe the younger version of the the the
deathless mother then
but she also looked a bit whiter than
jennifer actually is yeah that's what
was confusing me yeah so why would the
deathless mother
because they all appeared in very
specific forms that were reflective
of other
i'm like is that people
and then i thought about the
you know the um
the leshi
no no no with the jennifer stop talking
about yannick oh sorry the hundreds the
hunchback the hump
yeah and
then it's like i guess it can't be her
then who is this because i kept spending
because like they established that one
is like the the prophet for
elf people yeah and the other one is
nilfgaard person
and then for jennifer i was like who's
this supposed to be yeah for sure
so i was like is it just young jennifer
and how she like imagined her herself so
but if it is a young version of the
deathless mother
then
maybe she is mother to
jennifer in some way no wait they said
they gave birth that was one of those
i'm sure i remember episode two
were they lying about like we had a
child and she [ __ ] took yeah they had
to be alive because her dad was like her
dad's half elf yeah so she was one of
those like orphan children who brought
into them right so maybe maybe she is
yeah and then she has the connective
tissue huh yeah yen less mother over
here maybe we just wasted our time
pondering this thoughts
you're way off on this story let me tell
you what happens in episode six clears
it up
let me route you over to the short story
that this came from yeah yeah but i
really like that that sequence and i
love that they played it as this yeah
shared experience but that's very
personalized to each of them and the way
that it scatters them by the end of it
and puts yeah frangilla
for a momentary alliance at least with
uh with uh
francesca the elven lady
uh and yeah i don't know i like the
greatness of which they played that
because you still don't really know at
the end of it whether this was a a
sinister or
a more benevolent
albeit creepy in uh encounter so
i like that i'm pretty sure it's a
creepy benevolent encounter john did you
see the lady did you see how she behaved
yeah she manipulates them through
nightmares it seemed like something was
off but i can see the show doings i can
see them taking her out where it's like
yeah sometimes
a real premonition that you can actually
apply is gonna be a little unnerving
but i don't know it does it definitely
reads as sus yeah they're gonna see her
out of the woods and she's just shopping
hey
hey the table
i'm only deathless when i'm in the cabin
when i'm out here i am in stock that's
just an attraction that i had
nothing what are they doing milf carter
the elves are trying to get along oh wow
that's not what i had in mind
okay
jeez i thought you guys could take a
joke you guys just took that and the
disaster that acid insurance came into
the woods man
sorry guys it's late it's been a kind of
stressful day too before filming this
um
but yeah that was uh
that was a good sequence it really was
really was trippy and i think this show
does a great job too at the
transitioning back and forth i thought
the whole thing with the lashi was
freaking uh insane looking i haven't
seen the green knight but i kept
thinking of the
that's
creature
good call um like the trailers for the
green knives that i kept flashing too
and i thought they would have thought
you could actually kill off best mirror
in this episode but they don't which is
great because that would have sucked the
biggest fattest balls in the world um i
thought i heard something about vestimir
is like an actual like an ongoing
character that appears in like the video
games too yeah i don't know the details
of i i've played the game so i don't
know that's something i heard i could
see the show doing its own thing um
i thought it was like would they kill
him off here and then the other witcher
got to know eskel
who
was he is he always kind of like the
sleazy [ __ ] or or is it just the
lushy because i'm like it's hard for me
to care about you dying when you really
just seem like from the second we saw
you that you were like
it's just gonna you're just like gross
from the from the get-go
but the effects that they had on the
leshi were awesome this like that i
noticed they've been putting their
creatures in real dark lightning lately
which is great because it makes it look
that much more real
and um it was a real like
uh uh hasson butty horror experience
uh yeah it was it was it was torturous
watching that but man was it beautiful
to behold like there were times from
like what is any of this practical
because some of the shots make it look
pretty freaking real and tangible
and uh yeah that was that's some good
stuff watching them work together i do
wish i kind of
saw some other sides of the esko to kind
of give a [ __ ] about something like that
that's why i'm hoping we stay
in um
in uh uh
cal one uh conlon yeah yeah care morgan
right here morgan we stay in karen
warren to get to know the other witchers
watch uh siri you know kind of
train a little bit more
uh especially because like while she has
her powers she also has a grandmother
who was just a [ __ ] and ass warrior so
you know that fighter with a blade is in
her as well oh yeah
bloodlust is deep buried within and they
do so much of these fantasy the fantasy
properties often do it but this show in
particular does a lot with parenting and
lineage and inheritance
so i'm interested to see how siri comes
into her own and i really like the
connection that they have with each
other gerald and siri this like
this uh this purpose and bond that they
that maybe they themselves don't quite
understand maybe syria more than geralt
because siri
you know like
[ __ ] depends on him and it needs him
to survive
uh where geralt has you know he lived
with the weight of this law of surprise
forever but i think he
has a heart for her more than he
expected to and less of a burden of like
i didn't want to take care of this girl
it feels like they have a real actual
bond together yeah those looks of things
changes that they have and they're like
we don't really know how to talk to each
other but when it comes down to it when
they're
they they find hope in one another and i
think they find a kinship because you
know it's it's a thread that's played in
a lot of things but i thought it it rang
true pretty true truer than i've seen in
a lot of places here where uh vesamir i
think is talking to ernie it's a little
pretty true
yeah that ain't true pretty true true or
truest the truthiest that's right no
none more truthful
than this portrayal
but uh best of here when he's talking to
her and he's you know giving her these
different prompts just about their world
and continually being like wow you're
really not shaken up by any of this like
i i bought that level too and i think
that that goes to serve her relationship
with geralt is like her childhood while
obviously very pampered for part of it
you know has become something very harsh
and very survival based
was two yeah and so yeah i think that's
a nice thread that backs that up of like
when they start training it is a really
beautiful kind of graceful uh shared
moment between them and it comes out of
what vestemir says you know that lesson
learned about yeah i'm protecting you by
teaching you to protect yourself rather
than just shielding you from things
that's a good point but yeah serious uh
personality seems to
so supportive right now i'm not
like testified like
yeah i'm gonna roll right now like
you're my hype man you're my interactive
feedback
i love it i want every review to be like
i just haven't like shut up this is
listening no no i love it it's good i
feel very supported and that's wonderful
you're like my vessemeer
you know yeah
i can't get you defend for yourself
and you don't have that much faith that
i can handle blade burn
but it's okay for your escorts
and that's the thing too is yeah i mean
eskel doesn't seem like he like if the
point of of the things that happen in
shadow of the nightmare of the wolf is
like yeah vesamir had to make a change
to the whole order of witchers and raise
these kids to actually have some kind of
moral compass seems like eskel missed
all of that yeah by his behavior so i uh
yeah i i do kind of share that like it
would have been nice if he had some
redeeming quality well it seems like
they were staying at the leshi a lot i
don't know that seems like we get new
monsters all the time but
you know the the they seem to
emphasize the fact
that
you know like the less you're dying out
and they can't reproduce
and um
then when you see how it like took over
eskel
it seemed like this is their new way
they can reproduce
so i wonder if this monster might be a
little bit more of an ongoing
thread in some way i'm worried about
that wound
i don't know like as much as harold
spoon yeah cause as much as the end of
the episode didn't seem like it was more
than that they made like the way they
shot that happening felt very deliberate
and it felt like he was going out of his
way to stab him versus
yeah yeah so i think there is a bit more
to unpack but then i don't know maybe
i'm wrong in the next episode there's
nothing
they just drop it yeah it's gonna be
because yeah uh uh what's his name like
you just you set this up and then and
then um um
vessemer
is
when when geralt tells him you know like
it took over him that it transformed him
you've estimated like that's impossible
so they they've set up something more
with the lesshe yeah
but
isn't that the name of a soap lush
they've set up the leshi
imagine leshi's soap
you know he's just made out of real
barking start to grow out of your
bathtub instead of colorful bubbles
yeah
my lushy bath bomb yeah
so it seems like there's a seed planted
there
but this is this is um that was a second
stroke
so yeah it's it seems like there's
there's more to a pack but
i am enjoying the season
the fact that it's just so damn linear
it feels very different yeah so now it
feels like they're building up to like
this
giant crescendo of something and less
about like what's
how's this connect yeah watching the
connective so it's a different
audience
viewing perspective
the connection feels like it's intended
now to be more direct than lyrical very
character
yeah
especially like i like that the past
couple of episodes jennifer has been
able to do anything she's so magicked
out yeah she's got a web block she
didn't even car
hey
i will not say where that comes from oh
yeah no no no uh from you know like when
the internet crashes
yeah it's a good show
anyway guys listen
tell us is esco your favorite witcher
comment down below uh do you like the
actor who plays
were you expecting somebody else perhaps
more anthony hopkins from
the mask of zorro hmm
great pull that's kind of what it looks
like a great pool uh-huh it is or or
kind of like that i am
spanish with a british accent and a
white face that's right that's right all
those british spaniards
yeah
anyway guys
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button relate to filming hawkeye let's
go
[Music]